without looking down because you get a little
scared
[Music]
that's why he always tells you that it's not that it
's better to be careful
[Music]
when you approach a castle it's
as if you approach a  heart that is
breaking down
[Music]
the castle is something that is alive
castle moves it has its inertia
and when you are there you move with it
[Music]
my first time I did a casting I
was quite moved
[Music]
to
[  Applause]
well I came here to Catalonia in 1957
my cousin took me to a castellers performance
and I saw it and it impressed me as a child and I
said to myself I almost have the castle
we are not professionals but my life has
been more than 20 years  years is dedicating myself to
making castles
for me it is a way of life not
in this saint four years my first
major festival was four months old and I have
photos in the square that my daughter had
taken me to see us
and this week I have seen more of the  people
from the group that my mother
[Music]
I have 10  years old I play a net elche in
which he raises his hand
I started when I was seven years old
[Music]
I am 11 years old
when I used to go down the street always in his
life everywhere
when I companies the castell
there were precisely 78 dicks and now there are almost 60  70
laps everyone has the passion that you have
the fact that you are looking for
a common goal with us
a link with all the people and with the
castle that is essential
[Music]
what is a castle in a structure that
you  it deserves a lot of effort and that it lasts so
little that sometimes he asks you if it is
worth the effort you have given it
if a castle ten pesos
we always say a thousand people it can be 900 800
at the base
in 4 of 10 on the second floor they go 80
and on the third floor there are 40
is where you can end up stepping on your boss
and nothing happens
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
and it
is a lot of people who come together from
all societies of all social levels
of all ages  It can be
a  a doctor a carpenter a trowel and
nothing happens he lives very well
[Music]
when he was upstairs he looked down a little
and to those below him moving a lot it's like
you fly a little and then land
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] it
's dangerous
man we hurt ourselves
[Music]
more than afraid about it because I feel
very high and very difficult to do studies
the children are afraid we are bad they are
people
[Music]
[Music  ]
I've been to the hospital many times to see
children,
and building castles isn't easy.
You have to like them a lot because you keep
quiet. It's
very normal for people to cry with
joy and emotion. Castles are hard, no matter how hard they are.
you like it and you feel it and
you feel a special thing you carry in
your blood
[Music
] life evolves so much that you don't know
how far the human person can go
I don't think we are not at the
maximum point
there is no limit new castells it is a
fact of  train and prepare better
if you tell me do you think that at some time it
will be possible to be a castle of 11
I am not going to say no
[Music]
and the definition of the castells is
a union of the efforts of a whole lot
of people
of various colors and  all social levels
[Music]
to achieve a common goal, which is
Spanish,
you end up really creating a big
family
[Music]
with all the families there is always
some dispute, some opinion found
in
but it doesn't go beyond that, they are opinions and
even that's how  the total integration school works
[Music]